professor Julian syrup member of the
Nobel Committee could please describe to
us why our cells need to use Auto foggy
or selfie day so at Apogee you know
comes from the Greek terminology of cell
feedings and without at Apogee our cells
won't survive we need at Apogee to ward
off invading molecules for example to
deal with very large proteins that might
be long-lived or perhaps defective so we
need to be able to have a cup of tea to
degrade proteins but we also need a tapa
G for renewal in other words we need a
tapa G to break down proteins for a
self-reliance what was the state of
knowledge before the worker that C is
laureate Yoshinori Osumi started his
work on this problem in the 1990s and
before that time people understood that
the cell had a lysosome or in his case a
vacuole and in the yeast people thought
that the vacuole was like a a waste dump
people didn't know much about molecules
like the the tofu G process but they
could see that morphologically existed
in the cells so the machinery was
unknown and how the system was working
was unknown and whether or not it was
involved in disease was also unknown
it's like a biological enigma
I think that dr. eschew me was
interested in working on problems that
other investigators stayed away from if
it's out to the blue the discoveries
that the key finding sock what's the
first step here dr. su me work with
yeast cells and they're relatively
simple cell it's a singular cell it's an
organism with one cell and he was
interested in understanding things under
the microscope so the first problem he
wanted to tackle was whether or not
these yeast cells had a coffee chief so
he created a really ingenious way of
studying them he developed cells that
didn't degrade proteins in the lysosome
and he reasoned that if he could stop
the degradation process he could see an
accumulation of of the atashi machinery
in these cells so he looked at yeast
cells under the microscope and he
subjected them to starvation that
induces ecology and he could see an
accumulation of a phagosome in the cell
so he could look at this end of the
microscope in these they were these this
machinery was moving under the
microscope you could see them visually
so that was the first step then when he
had a system where he could see an
accumulation of at egg effect auto
phagosome x' in the cell he could then
study these yeasts by inducing a
chemical that led to mutations and he
reasoned that if he could mutate the
genes that were important for otology he
may be able to then identify genes that
regulated this process so he could
scream these yeast cells that were
chemically modified and he identified 15
genes that were important for the auto
process for etapa gene he then
went on in the third step to clone the
gene products and he could study the
proteins that were a part of this auto
machinery he could study that
this process was response
distress starvation and that involved a
cascade of proteins that came together
in complexes and he could study these
protein complexes and how the auto
phagosome was formed and how that was
used with the lysosome and how the
contents of the auto phagosome were
degraded in the cells since to me this
is a very complex system and in order to
describe this price in an accessible way
is there a metaphor one could use so I
think you could think of early on the
lysosome or the vacuole was seen as sort
of a waste dump and before Osumi came on
the scene people understood that that
waste dump was in the south but what he
showed was that it wasn't a waste dump
it was a recycling plant this was a
really sophisticated machinery that
recycled damaged or long-lived proteins
and they were reused so if you think of
this example every day we need to
replace about two to three hundred grams
of protein in our body every two to
three months every protein in our body
turns over because of etapa G these two
to 300 grams of protein are are made
we're eating proteins every day about 70
grams of protein but that's not enough
to take care of the requirement to make
new proteins because of this machinery
we're able to rely on some of our own
proteins maybe the damaged proteins or
the long-lived proteins and they're
recycled with the sophisticated
machinery so that we can sustain and we
don't and we survive also this crisis or
Physiology or medicine so
what would be the medical implications
on this recite that this award is for
fundamental physiology that's right but
it really has a very strong implication
for different diseases so for example we
can think of with starvation
we need this process to survive
starvation because we can have a self
renewal of our own proteins so we can
survive that's one thing we also need
this process for embryogenesis
we need this process for cell division
we need this process to be functioning
for normal physiology there's examples
of where this process is important to
ward off diseases for example if you
have a bacteria or a virus that infects
a cell we need this machinery to be able
to ward off viral infections the
machinery is also important for diseases
associated with aging so for example if
we have damaged or toxic proteins they
need to be handled if they're not
handled correctly they can build up and
that can lead to diseases like neuro
generative diseases Alzheimer's
Parkinson's maybe diabetes if you have
too much etapa genes that may be
associated with cancer and the tumor
cells may survive so too much is not
good and too little is not good as well
so if you need to turn to our attention
to the laureate who is he so Yoshinori
Osumi is still an active researcher
today he was born in 1945 so he's 71
years old he just recently published a
paper and he's still working today on
the cell biology and the structural
biology of the auto fetchick machinery
so he's very very active as a scientist
even yet today he's a professor emeritus
at the Tokyo Institute of Technology of
course in Japan
and finally as the Nobel Committee being
able to reach Professor just this
morning professor Pearlman the Secretary
of the Nobel Assembly had a telephone
conversation he he got him on the first
number we had on our list he was in his
office in his lab and I think he was
very delighted I think that he was
surprised he wasn't expecting this and
he's looking forward to coming to visit
us all in Stockholm